Hello. My name is Hiu. On behalf of Expert Village,...
...I'm going to show several everyday Chinese dishes.
Heat the wok over high heat. Add three tablespoons of cooking oil.
And we will precook the beef slice before we do the stir-fry.
The purpose of this precooking process is to just get the beef around medium well...
...but we don't want it overcooked.
As you see, there's still some pink color in the beef slice.
That is what we are looking for in the precooking process.
Then, leave the heat high. Add two to three tablespoons of oil again.
And we will add the mixture of green onion, ginger, garlic and shallot...
...and stir-fry them really well until you see the shallots look transparent...
...and the green onions have become soft in texture.
Then, we go add the beef slice back to the wok, so that we will fully cook the beef...
...and we just want to stir-fry the beef for around 20 seconds.
Then, add the sauce to the mixture and give one final toss,...
...so that the sauce is mixed with all the ingredients.
And then, we can put the dish on the plate.
As you see, the stir-fry beef is ready.